Okay, so if I wanted to try to reduce my breast tumors with natural hormone blockers,
what do I try?
I'm only on the clear dip now.
I'm not going to sit here and tell you that taking a whole bunch of natural hormone blockers
is going to reduce your tumor.
But if you want to add to that, you could add a Roma clear, type it in here.
You could add a product that is called a Roma clear.
You could add a product called Astro clear.
They're all a little bit different.
So Roma clear has three different estrogen decreases, key laders, binders, astro clear
is a linked product that helps decrease estrogen.
So for the side by U.S. enzymes is the same thing as the uncle clear with myronase from
the side of the gym that you asked about before, but it gets a much better quality product.
So if you're going to start with one of these, I would start with this one, and I would
take three to six per day, if you really want to hit it hard.
And then the other thing that you could take that helps dislodge.
So these are things that will decrease bad estrogens.
And there's another thing that will help dislodge bad estrogens from the receptor site itself.
The idea about bad estrogens and ER positive cancers is that the estrogen block this
certain estrogen receptor on the cell membrane of a cancer, and that estrogen receptor is
actually an apoptotic receptor.
So it's blocking apoptosis.
The one thing that's been shown to help remove this is the Highland 951.
So Highland 951 is a fermented soy.
It's a liquid.
It comes in a bottle.
Eight ounces.
And actually, the manufacturer suggests that you take one bottle per day.
Now, probably this is an expensive product.
I think it's $59 bucks for a bottle.
You're taking $59 bottle a day on it.
Well, if you're really, really, really trying to avoid any medical things, you know, that's
a choice that you have to make.
Now, we have people taking anywhere between one and six tables, foods a day, which can be
a third of a bottle.
We have some people that are taking a bottle a day to try that for 30 days or 60 days might
be a choice to take.
Another thing that I just did it talked about last week, I just did an interview with the
product, the order of the company that I don't think it's been released yet, is, is
been a gene in its higher dose is the salo acetate.
I think it's called.
It's called fat.
Fatigue.
And it's oxalo acetate, fat mass or something like that.
And that's in the higher dose.
So this is a very expensive product too.
It costs about $500 a bottle, but a bottle lasts you one month.
So it's actually cheaper than the highlight that they've actually done studies on this with
breast cancer.
The oxalo acetate, this high dose, oxalo acetate, take it as directed out of the bottles.
I think it's repills a day.
The bottle will last you one month.
It's a pricey product, but they've shown that it's taken stage for breast cancer people
with whatever their revision.
Now, I just talked to the owner, he couldn't say that in the interview, so it won't be anything
like that in the interview.
It's called oxalo acetate CFS, because the only thing they can talk about it with is chronic
fatigue syndrome.
But we actually have people buy it with very, very serious chronic fatigue syndrome and
post-COVID, long haul COVID, because it's shown to take away those symptoms.
And the metamorphosis pathway that it's disturbed is the blockages that a person has in the
crib cycle that pushes energy consumption for cancer patients into the warburg effect.
So you basically are blocking the warburg effect.
So it can actually be theoretically, it could be good for any type of cancer.
Originally, the studies on oxalo acetate were on astrocytoma and glioblastoma, and now
they're actually, as I told you everybody, this last week, that they're just starting
to study with Mayo Clinic on glioblastoma with oxalo acetate this month.
So very promising, nutraceutical, that you could get just over the color.
It's just a pill that you take, there's really no side effects with.
It's just crazy.
We have a couple of people on it, really haven't had enough time to see if it's really going
to make a difference, yeah.